president trump is apparently halting
his plan to shut down the popular video
app
tick tock in the u.s reuters reports the
president will give the chinese owned
platform 45 days to sell its u.s
operations
to microsoft tic toc claims to have 100
million american users luigi jang is at
the white house with more on this ouija
good morning
good morning jeff president trump can
add tick tock's parent company to a list
of foreign entities that present a
threat to national security
last year the government added bite
dance which owns tick tock
and opened an investigation into them
and branches of the military have
already
banned the app from government-issued
phones if that microsoft deal falls
through it could impact
millions more american users right here
in the u.s
[Music]
it's the world's newest social media
sensation
you can't let me know where you're going
because you can't say it so
what we gonna do about that tick-tock is
home to dozens of viral dance challenges
silly videos who's funnier
in celebrity cameos
but the wildly popular app has become a
source of bipartisan concern
over its chinese ownership all the data
that goes into those mobile apps that
kids have so much fun with
and seems so convenient it goes right to
servers in china right to the chinese
military the chinese communist party
i have been very opposed to tick-tock i
was one of the first to expose the
chinese links
and i have urged that tick-tock be
closed down in america
tick-tock disputes the security concerns
and said in a statement that u.s user
data is stored
in the u.s with strict controls on
employee access
we're building the safest app because we
know it's the right thing to do
tick-tock also says its biggest
investors come from the u.s
and has committed to hiring 10 000
americans in the coming years
the app has recently become a platform
for some anti-trump activists
we're doing very well in oklahoma in
june some users led a coordinated effort
to disrupt president trump's campaign
rally in tulsa
by encouraging people to register for
the event online
but not show up we may be banning tick
tock we may be doing some other things
and comedian sarah cooper gained a
massive social media following with her
videos
mocking the president's speeches and
interviews
we're closing in on a solution mr
trump's closest advisors claim
any action including the sale of the app
to a u.s company would better protect
the personal data
of millions of americans for a long time
a long time the united states just said
well goodness if we're having fun with
it or if a company can make money off of
it
we're going to permit that to happen
president trump has said
enough and we're going to fix it china
responded to secretary pompeo's remarks
this morning saying it is firmly opposed
to
any u.s actions against chinese software
companies
meanwhile microsoft says its acquisition
of the app is still
subject to a complete security review
vlad would you jang at the white house
for us wija thank you very much